today on stick to football it's a whole
new stick to football because Connor and
I are on camera today he's New York I'm
a Missouri you can watch the show now on
Bleacher Report's youtube page you can
see us in the Bleacher Report app but
most importantly buddy I love that who
do you or we're looking looking good I
kept this one in the back pocket from
Vegas man I had to leave something here
so I'm glad you're putting on for the
stick to football brand right now but I
can't say that I am besides the the
football helmet here it's good to be on
video it's good to be home
how are you doing recovery wise here
after that long time on Pacific time not
great because because people can see
there's bags under my eyes it's just
it's been an adjustment going eight days
in Pacific time and coming home but but
we got a lot of news to talk about today
which is you know it's it's in season
now for us so a lot of the show is gonna
be a lot of news draft notes game notes
and the biggest event and honestly maybe
in my football career as a writer is
that Andrew Luck unexpectedly announced
his retirement well he didn't get a
chance to announce it Adam Schefter
announced it Saturday night during the
the Colts preseason game and that's
really where I want to start today
talking to you and we can we can start
right there actually Andrew Luck tell us
a couple people hey I'm gonna retire
probably tomorrow on Saturday night it
gets to Adam Schefter and shefter puts
it on Twitter says hey Andrew Luck's
gonna retire shocks the world really I
mean we saw Colts fans react we saw
close players react we saw you know
analysts and fans react on Twitter but
where this starts is Adam Schefter
breaking the news do you take any issue
with shefter doing that and not letting
Andrew Luck have his moment and make his
announcement well I think it's tough to
I think Adam Schefter is paid by ESPN to
be the best news breaker in the football
industry I think it's a really tough
situation to sit here and say how could
he do this but at the same time it
obviously led to really poor results
Matt with him being essentially booed
off the field it created very emotional
reactionary moments from Colts fans
which I didn't like but at the same time
I think we can understand
why they were so upset and you really
have to feel bad for Andrew Luck could
forget the the god-awful takes on
Twitter about him you know it being soft
for not wanting to rehab and all that
nonsense it was ridiculous so I think
when you look at it it's hard to sit
here and say anyone else in the world
would have sat on that kind of news
considering Adam Schefter didn't but you
can also say created what was
essentially a pretty shitty situation
Matt it really was and and I I want to
chime in on this if if that news he got
to me before I got shefter I would have
tweeted that as soon as my little
fingers could have typed it out that is
his job like you said he's paid by ESPN
to break news he's not paid by the Colts
and he's definitely not paid to I mean
to protect the feelings of players
unfortunately I mean it's just this is
the world we live in where news is so
valuable and so important especially
when it comes to the NFL you got to get
that out there as fast as possible so
that someone doesn't beat you to it so I
think Schaeffler was just doing his job
now I've actually heard from a lot of
people within the Colts organization
after this happened I've talked to a
couple Colts players I've read other
people's reactions to this and I thought
it was interesting Darius Leonard who is
probably now the one of the leaders of
this team said that at first he was
actually angry and then he had time to
like go home and think about it and I'm
not in any way trying to validate the
fans who booed because I think that's
just it's low-class it really is but I
can understand being upset especially in
the heat of the moment that here you are
two weeks before the season and your
quarterback just retired now that does
need context you got to step back and
say okay this guy has been so hurt in
his seven-year career that we understand
why he's walking away and that it might
actually be to the benefit of the team
down the road because of the injuries
because of his salary there's a lot of
different ways that this can actually
benefit the cold but I think mostly Matt
a lot of people just forgot the long
list of injuries he's dealt with since
being drafted he's been beat up he
didn't have an offensive line for many
many years during the Ryan Greeks in era
so that was an issue we even saw a
couple viral clips of him I remember one
on the sidelines of him trying to
convince Coach Pagano that he wanted to
come back in and they needed to protect
him so this is
somebody that was soft this is not
somebody that did not try to play
through pain many many times this is
someone that hit the breaking point at
29 years old that right now it was time
to hang him up he feels he he wants to
live a long life he has other interests
that I remember talking to somebody you
know that is very plugged in around the
league especially the Colts organization
and they said 16 18 months ago they had
already started her rumblings that he
was getting tired of the injuries that
he had other life interests off the
field and that the Colts didn't really
react the way the fans did where they
were like okay this is something that
has been a possibility for over a year
now and one more injury was all that
really took I don't know if he even
would have been ready for the regular
season this year but it finally hit the
breaking point where he feels it's the
right thing to walk away from this game
right now
and I understand being upset about it
because I'm I'm old enough to remember
when Barry Sanders did this and I was
heart broke because I love Barry Sanders
and he was the best running back in
football and he walked away
you're old enough to remember Brett
Favre you know we're talking it bouncing
around you know dabbling with coming
back and you know we've seen Calvin
Johnson do it we've seen Rob Gronkowski
do it and so I will just say this even
if even if my homes did this next week
and he's my favorite player in the NFL I
think that my standpoint from now on
would just be I'm not that player I
cannot speak on their decision-making I
wish them the best now from a football
standpoint I don't think Jacoby brisance
a bad option there's a reason they trade
it for this guy there's a reason they've
kept him and of course this works out
perfectly he's on the last year of a
rookie deal so we get a year basically
to see what type of quarterback Jacoby
bris it can be and I think that one one
thing I tweeted out Sunday I spoke to
some Colts people and they said you know
this team was built to win not to win
with Andrew but to win and they think
that JB can be the guy to get it done
and I love that that this team believes
they're not laying down they're not a
lot of people are saying well are they
gonna tank again because if you remember
at the after the Peyton Manning era it
was basically okay you know we're gonna
tank now they get Andrew Luck it's like
they've gone from
great quarterback too great quarterback
and a lot of people are probably sitting
there wondering can they really do this
again and end up with two Otunga by Lowa
Justin Herbert somebody along that line
or maybe they're just they're just not
God could you imagine that's not
actually crazy but they're just not
gonna be a bad football team this year
which a kobe per say I think they have a
lot of pieces on defense they still have
good playmakers on offense and a strong
offensive line per set has to be jacked
up about this opportunity to finally be
the guy when he's flashed in so many
different instances so I think when you
look at it can we sit here and say that
perset is a franchise quarterback that
would be ridiculous we haven't seen
enough but can we sit here and say he
has the talent to become one I think so
I think he can make every single throw
he's got a phenomenal arm he moves well
he seems like a bright guy I think
greatly great great leader I think
there's some examples of him maybe that
decision-making needs to be sped up he's
holding on to the ball too long but of
course every quarterback that hasn't
played a lot has things to work on so if
you're a Colts fan you're not expected
to be you know ready to move on from the
Andrew Luck era but if there's something
to look forward to is your quarterback
that's coming in is not Curtis Painter
this time you have somebody that's
exciting to watch oh my god yeah it's
not Jim Shoji you have a decent
quarterback well I I don't know I would
change them as my pick to win the AFC
South I would actually go to the Texans
but I still think this is a really
really good team moving on to another
player that has constantly been in the
news Ezekiel Elliott basically the
negotiations have hit the press and hit
the public and we now feel reasonably
confident that the Cowboys have offered
him a deal that make him the second
highest-paid running back in the NFL
behind Todd Gurley and so I mean you've
posed the question should he take the
deal and I am going to say yes and the
whole reason that I'm going to say yes
is because your favorite team has a
running back who when he decided to hold
out was in my opinion the best running
back in football and he bet on himself
and he lost 15 million dollars and I
know these guys are gonna make 100
million dollars in their career and that
doesn't seem like a lot of money
it is it is a lot of money no matter how
much money you have you only have so
many years as a running back to make
money so if I'm Zeke I swallow my pride
a little bit and say okay I want a ton
of this guaranteed I want a ton of it
upfront but I'm gonna take my 20 million
a year or whatever it might be and I'm
going to play ball for the next four or
five years because after that he's
really at the end of his prime and he's
at the end of his you know high-value
earning phase of his career basically I
think the one thing that levian taught
us is if you're running back holding out
is not gonna work for you I think one of
your last points was the most important
to me and that is how much of this money
is guaranteed that's the most important
thing to me because I think something
that happened with the levy on
negotiations with Pittsburgh was we saw
these inflated numbers thrown around
whether it was 45 60 mil all these kinds
of numbers and nobody really knew the
guarantees what was the real money in
that what was the security and that's
something a levy on has always been
public about is I needed long-term
security in this game when my body is
handling the load of 400-plus touches a
year I think when you look at Zeke right
now we see this phrase thrown around
second highest pay running back that
sounds great that money and he's a young
player a really young player where if he
gets that four or five year deal mat
maybe he can cash in similarly to a Matt
Forte did one last time when Matt Forte
was up on that big money deal at the end
of Chicago he got one more decent
contract with the Jets Zeke is somebody
that might be 28 29 years old and maybe
can get another two or three year kind
of deal so that's why it's so important
for him to get this contract on now you
could hit the market maybe one more time
assuming your body holds up but most
importantly is forget the annual average
per year because it is a pride thing he
of course he wants to be the number one
guy but if you can get the most
guaranteed money that's what you need to
be holding out for and that's what you
should come back for if Dallas is
willing to pony up like we haven't seen
these numbers manipulated before so that
when you know when shefter and Rappaport
tweeted out they can say oh the most
money for running back ever make it the
most guarantee that's all that matters
running back ever know
[ __ ] cares after that like just just
do it just give him the guaranteed money
over two years front-load the [ __ ] out
of it and then you have money to sign
DAC and Amari Cooper and Layton Vander
ash and everyone else down the road I
think that's how they have to do it now
a team that the Cowboys will be facing
this year their rival the Washington
Redskins they have a mess on their hands
which I know no one is surprised about
because they're the Redskins this Trent
Williams situation is insane to me
now last week while we were in Vegas he
got leaked that a team had offered the
Patriots I believe was the team had
offered a first-round pick and
Washington said no so to me that says
okay they're leaking this hoping that
someone offers a mid first-round pick or
a package that includes a first and then
a kicker you know a third or fourth or
pick I don't understand what they're
waiting for because he has said I will
never play for you again you have to
move him while you can still get
something in return
sitting around waiting and I know this
is the opposite of what we just said was
II click you got to take your money when
you can get it
left tackle and running back could not
be more different at the position value
trail Williams if he's never gonna play
for you again you you have to trade his
ass and try to get something in return
Matt this is simply called lacking
awareness is what this is Trent Williams
just turned 31 years old this summer he
is arguably the best offensive tackle in
football and Washington is not a team
right now
that plans on winning this year they
just drafted a quarterback in the first
round they seemed hell-bent on sitting
him if you were gonna play Dwayne
Haskins right away then you want Trent
Williams back because Haskins is a guy
that we've seen needs time he needs time
in the pocket he's not great on the move
when you give him that clean pocket is
when that lively arm comes to play and
he can pick apart secondaries if you're
gonna sit Haskins go get the return now
for Trent Williams while you can for a
31 year old player his value is still
extremely high because he plays at an
elite level at a premium position and a
market where multiple contenders hello
Cleveland Browns and maybe New England
Patriots could use the
kind of caliber of an offensive lineman
at this point of the season and short
Williams is telling everyone I'm not
coming back I don't want to play for
them and now we're seeing the reports
that he's healthy so it's not even I'm
not healthy I'm not coming back good say
[ __ ] you I'm not playing for you anymore
so with Trent this is an ugly situation
I have like liked a lot of things
Washington has done recently this is not
one of them and they should capitalize
on his value immediately and I know I've
had a lot of people tweet me why doesn't
Washington just trade him for Houston
for Jadeveon Clowney that's not even
even Washington doesn't need you to it's
not even they drafted it also that but
they drafted Montes what they have Ryan
Kerrigan
they have Ryan Anderson they don't need
Jadeveon Clowney especially for a
one-year rental
I mean Houston needs shrimp with like
crazy ass no doubt but they don't have a
general manager to execute this trade so
they can't do it I'm with you man there
are so many teams that could use Trent
Williams a New England is one for sure
there are many teams that that could do
better
yeah nailed left tackle but [ __ ] Joe
Staley has looked terrible in the pie
now I would take Chet Williams like Eric
Fisher it might be holding the Chiefs
offensive line back I'm sure they would
take Trent Williams if there are so many
team if I was John Dorsey I would try to
first-round picks for Trent Williams
right now Oh Cleveland definitely does
you first-rounders you have a built to
win right now team that needs a
franchise tackle so see if you can get
Josh ducks and while you're at it cuz
your receiver depth isn't great and
apparently they're gonna try to move
they just cut jaelen strong who's having
a good camp finally we've waited years
for this for Jalen strong it isn't it
amazing that and I've this is my ninth
year covering the NFL every time I start
to think oh man Washington figured it
out look at this good draft they have
they're figuring it out they just go and
like [ __ ] themselves over and over again
and it's you know it's like as long as
Dan Snyder has his hands in the football
this is what's gonna yeah that's the
problem and I hope for Trent he ends up
on a contender and I hope for Washington
because I want to see Dwayne task and
succeed I hope they get some serious
capital back
they can keep building that team in next
year's first round so speaking of guys
that need to be moved to Davie on clowny
you brought it up already Matt this
thing is just dragging out man is there
gonna be any solution to this by the end
of by the end of the preseason here I
think there could be I know that this is
something they have been very torn about
for a long time and I talked about it on
this show before the draft that there
was you know some rumors that he might
be traded but they were asking for
basically three picks you know so it
would be a - I get two four six tight
package and that's that's just a random
number out there but that that's kind of
what they were looking for and then I
like last week some people tried to
start stuff on Twitter that maybe Tyreke
Hill would get traded for Jadeveon
Clowney that would shock the hell out of
me just mean yes it's a need for Kansas
City but trading Tyreke Hill would blow
my mind especially I don't know why
Houston would do that it really doesn't
make any sense so I can't completely
squash that rumor but it doesn't line up
logically but when we look at where
someone like clowny could land I mean
there are so many teams we could benefit
from this player who really was a rare
athletic talent when he came out of
college now he has been banged up a
little bit he maybe hasn't reached the
potential that we all expected coming
out of South Carolina but almost every
team could use a player like this and I
would think that you're not gonna trade
him within the AFC we've seen that
really happen a lot lately but pick a
team in the NFC they could basically
benefit from a dude like this I know we
just said Washington you know they've
drafted for depth there but man for the
Giants you could use Jadeveon Clowney if
you're the Falcons you could use to
Jimmy a clinic you're the Panthers
you're the Saints there are so many
teams it just run through the list of
contenders basically they could use a
player like this I would love to see the
Rams do it and I know like they've
traded so many assets in the past for
guys but it's usually worked out I would
love to see the RAM say you know what we
need another pass rusher we're basically
building year to year to try to win a
Super Bowl let's go get this guy I'm
with you all the way I think if you're a
win now team then cloudy comes into the
picture the problem is that teams have
you got to pay him and I don't know how
many teams feel comfortable paying right
now and why we're rumor squashing here
another one that's been attached to
clowny much like the one you've seen
Tyreke is that Robbie Anderson in the
picture as far as I could tell everyone
the Jets are obsessed with Robbie
Anderson specifically the head coach
Adam GaSe that's his favorite wide
receiver on the team so unless Joe
Douglas came in and has other plans and
isn't listening to Adam GaSe already
that one is not happening they have they
expect him to be their number one wide
receiver this year finally on the
rundown this is my favorite part of
today's around the league Carli Lloyd I
believe her manager has come out and
said there's been interest from two
teams not naming the teams for her to
kick in the preseason finales
this week I want to see Carli Lloyd do
this I'm so here for it I think she's
got to be better than most she's better
than Cody Park he's better than what man
was doing in New York or Taylor mode
were to let what I want this to happen
for so many reasons number one I think
she can I don't think this is a
publicity stunt I think Carli Lloyd
cannot shitta mentally kick a field goal
55 plus yards and she hasn't even been
specifically training for it yet which
is interesting it would give us a lot of
excitement for these final preseason
games and also something that I believe
she already spoke to I believe it was in
Peter Kings article the motivation it
would create four young girls watching
preseason football to see it one of the
best u.s. women's soccer players out
there on a football team would be
absolutely incredible and I truly think
Carli Lloyd can do this that's why I
want to see her give it a shot so yes
the the media part of me is like God
please this would be amazing yeah the
dad and me like I have a daughter who
has thank God or just no athletic talent
unfortunately we're not gonna ever see
Haley kicking the NFL but it's like that
part's cool like yes let's empower you
know young ladies and little girls to
believe they can do anything
yes that's amazing I also want to see
her kick against pressure because like
it's easy it's not easy it's very I
think kicking a field goal has to be one
of the hardest things that happens in
football it's easier to do that in
shorts on a practice field it's a lot
harder to do as we've seen from guys in
the NFL I mean boy was the second
pick it couldn't do it so I want to see
her kicking his pressure I would love to
see like your jets being you know what
we got a roster spot let's bring her in
let's let her kick throw some pads on
her you know there's gonna be some jerk
of a guy who's like trying to put her
shoulder on her after the kick or some I
hope not [ __ ] that guy
I want to see her kick against pressure
and then like my dream scenario is she
wins the Super Bowl you know it's like
she does an Adam Vinatieri has a field
goal as time expires to win a ring that
would be the coolest thing ever and I'll
say this I'll leave it at this she's won
a couple of World Cups already so the
pressure thing yeah it might be a little
different in a sport you're not familiar
with or haven't played at a pro level I
think she's been on the biggest stage of
the world before with her resume where
I'm pretty confident she'll be all right
Connor Miami vs Florida was a huge game
Saturday night week zero we were in
Vegas breaking this down all week the
game kind of went as we expected it was
sloppy this is what you get week zero it
was a much better game than I expected
from a competitive standpoint but we
want to talk about players who stood out
to us because this was really our first
chance to evaluate live football this
year I'll kick things off with jonathan
Greenert an edge rusher for florida
number 58 he was unstoppable coming off
the edge showing an amazing first step
really good leverage very good pad
height he and someone Elam it was not on
my radar outside of his name was on a
watch list because he's a grad transfer
basic he looked exploitive he looks
great like I can't wait to see him
against let's be honest the Miami
offensive line is not very good they're
very very young I can't wait to see him
as we get into SEC play see what what
type of player he can be against you
know the George's and Tennessee's LSU's
the the better competition I'm with you
all the way Matt I think the first thing
that stood out is how bad the Miami
offensive line was and because of that I
took another Florida defensive lineman
Jabari Zuniga he just took over this
game at times he had a couple sacks
tackles for a loss I know Greenert did
to these two front just made life very
uncomfortable for the young quarterback
Jaron Williams and I think to watch them
go to work whether it was a
working from the edge or shooting gaps
that went on the inside to get those
tackles for a loss there was times where
they were so both of them were so quick
off the ball that they had beaten the
tackles before they'd even picked their
head up off the snap so and that's the
kind of stuff we could take away two
different things here for the drafts
right Matt you have one where okay the
offensive line has to be quicker than
that but to it says a lot about their
first step and their experience these
are both experienced kind of guys I
think so I was excited to see both
Greenert and Zuniga really come out and
put on a show and and really light up
the stat the box score yeah I was
telling Melo because there was one time
they both got the ball so fast I was
like oh that's a false start it looks
like I was watching the love tackle and
it was like oh I'll set the left tackle
just yes like you just loved the ball
yeah so Greenert have one and a half
sacks six tackles he was all over the
place I do want to pray someone from
Miami two players actually from Miami
because they were stand out guys one is
not draft eligible so file the name away
but the first guy DJ Dallas at running
back is draft eligible a junior he was
fantastic I could not understand why he
didn't get the ball more and he only had
12 attempts but he averaged seven point
nine yards per attempt he had a
touchdown he caught four passes this guy
needs more than 16 touches a game he
needs 20 to 25 touches a game because he
has the type of talent while Miami
struggled in a lot of areas he is the
type of playmaker like I want to get the
ball too because he just stood out I
really throughout the game every time
thirteen got develop felt like something
big was gonna happen and then also when
the passing game was working for Miami
Florida could not stop true sophomore
tight end brevin Jordan now true
sophomore so he's not 2020 draft
eligible but you could not watch this
game and not just be blown away with how
good brevin Jordan looked they were
getting him utilized on screen passes
they were getting him utilized on dumps
he was just a matchup problem lining up
really all over the formation five
catches for 88 yards
I thought Florida did a better job in
the second half of matching up with him
but if I'm the Miami coaching staff man
Diaz has to figure out how to get DJ
Dallas and brevin Jordan involved more
moving forward at Brevard Jordan at
times took over that game or kept Miami
in the game at least and you look at J
Dallas that contact balance is very very
real some David Montgomery ish vibes
with that contact balance that he showed
the other night against some pretty poor
Florida tackling in the other game
Hawaii with the gigantic win a wild
last-second ceiling win over Arizona the
guy that got tackled at that one-yard
line is my standout player I love
watching Khalil Tate play Matt and he
looks healthy the arm looks a little
more lively he's still running for a
hundred yards here and there I think
he's a phenomenal playmaker and I think
in a league where we're seeing
Taysom Hill trace McSorely these guys
are getting opportunities to be
legitimate quarterbacks a Khalil Tate is
going to get his chance I know we've
talked about this before I said a long
time ago I'd even talked to evaluators
that love to Khalil Tate the football
player and figured out hey we'll find a
way to get him on the field at the next
level if he can play like he did against
Hawaii which is not guaranteed all the
time he's gonna be a legitimate
quarterback prospect in the picture so
just to watch his playmaking ability
from that position Arizona even when
they lose our must watch TV on this
college football season because of the
guy they have under center yeah JJ
Taylor in the backfield is another good
one it's well running back but I
actually so we didn't get to watch this
game Saturday night because none of the
casino bars were carrying this game so I
had to watch it when we got home I had
to watch it yesterday Monday the thing
that really surprised me was that Tate
did look healthy he looked more
explosive he looked more confident
because last year I didn't really feel
like he was gelling right in that
offense he still threw two picks it was
like the big take away from me so I'm
with you I don't feel like we can ever
look at thresholds and discount
quarterback prospects anymore the last
few years have taught us that I am
encouraged by what we've seen from
Khalil Tate the the feedback I've had
early this week is teams are still
looking at him as more of an athlete
unless as a quarterback but this is a
good first step 22 a 39 3 TDs
the
the two picks were there but this was a
good first step for him um this game was
just ugly to Cole McDonald the Hawaii
quarterback threw four touchdowns
he also threw four interceptions this
was one of the ugliest passing games
that I had the the displeasure of
watching it's gonna be fun though
because I do think Leo Tate is a guy
that we're gonna track and monitor
throughout the season as a senior and
just like with what Greenert is unita
these are you know potential prospects
that we're really gonna have our eyes on
to be be tracking throughout the year
Connor not only was there college
football on Saturday night there was a
ton of preseason football Friday and
Saturday week three normally the biggest
the most important and there were some
things that I think we can finally have
takeaways about when it comes to the
preseason because I have been out here
just any time someone has an opinion I'd
roll my eyes my gosh it's just the
preseason like come on
don't don't don't do this to me and one
thing that has really got me through the
last three weeks of Jimmy Garoppolo
struggling was that us just the
preseason I'm not gonna worry about it
but thank the Lord
Jimmy G looked good in week 3 against
Melos Kansas City Chiefs now the
question is does Jimmy G look better or
it's the Chiefs defense still bad and I
don't know the answer I do know this I'm
more worried about Joe Staley than I am
Jimmy Garoppolo Frank Clark ate his
lunch in this game I don't know if
Staley it's like you know I've been in
the league a long time
I'll be fine week one this is the second
week in a row I've seen him get
dominated by good defensive ends which
the NFC West is full of so I'm a little
worried about Garoppolo but Jimmy G
excuse me I'm a little worried about
Staley but Jimmy G did look better
I think Niner fans are at least backing
up off the cliff yeah this can give
Niner fans hopefully a little sigh
relief because it has not been a pretty
summer for Prince Aladin over there in
San Francisco so far and I mean with
Staley you can look out of this two ways
yes he's been beat more than were custom
to seeing this summer but Frank Clark
Matt is one of the best young pass
rushers in football and I think people
are forgetting how much better that
makes this Kansas City Chiefs team it's
a pretty scary situation but with Jimmy
you had to see this because we've seen
the interceptions in so over summer what
it's in training camp whether it's just
not good series in games I think him
trusting that knee is very important and
I'm not ready to say hey he looks back
to normal but at least it's the step in
the right direction executing the
offense not looking lost but they got to
protect this guy you have to keep him
upright you can't risk him getting hurt
again and this is a huge year for the
Niners for Jimmy G for Kyle Shanahan for
John Lynch they need to show that some
of these personnel decisions are not
only working on the field but also
executing from a coaching staff
standpoint so this was a really big one
for the San Francisco it really was and
for me it is just a little sigh of
relief we can back up Burnett God yeah
Frank Clark look Frank Clark looks
amazing the Saints offense no surprise
is going to be a juggernaut when you
have Drew Brees Allen Kamara and Michael
Thomas special things are gonna happen
but it feels like the Saints can't do
anything wrong offensively right now
it's like they have that golden touch
everything is working and the offensive
line that they've seemed to have found
the right mix in there with Eric McCoy
at center Andrew speed at left guard
they just have a really really good
group and I mean they're even getting
like Zach line involved at the full-back
position which I love this team is just
it really does feel like whatever Sean
Payton wants to do is working and
clicking at a very high rate yeah the
best triplets in football which are
Brees Michael Thomas and Alvin Kamara no
rust shown in this game I think the Jets
corners are a significant problem right
now I think they can give confidence to
anyone they just can't cover anyone
Jamal Adams is gonna be having be
bailing out a lot of people this season
I'll tell you that much but on the flip
side on the other side of this game
Sam's Arnolds with the touch touchdown
drive for the third straight preseason
game
I think there's been very promising
results for Sam heading into year two
with Adam GaSe now once again you said
it Matt how excited can we be about the
preseason this has to translate on the
field and we'll get a chance to do that
against a very tough defense against
Buffalo week one of this season I'm
excited for Donald and and this is a
conversation that you and mello myself
had a lot while he was at USC and last
year here's a player who threw a lot of
us in college a lot
he also had huge moments as Texas fans
we know that the overtime game at USC
one of the best performances I saw that
entire year because darn 'old is just so
poised if he can cut down on the picks
and I think that's where Adam GaSe the
system comes in then the rest of the NFL
should be really excited about d'Arnaud
because he's tough he's accurate he's
athletic enough I will say this I
understand that we have Baker mania
right now in the NFL I don't think the
gap is that large and this is very much
a wait-and-see because we really have
nothing to do that just a feeling it's
just an opinion
we have no analytics right now no stats
to back that up because it's just been
the preseason yeah but I will say as
excited as everyone is about Baker
I mean equally as excited about darn
'old and I think that's fair but I mean
Sam's not gonna be throwing to Odell
Beckham this year now it's good to see
him get a three down running back in
levy on bail we haven't even seen that
connection yet I think that's something
to be excited about here with Sam it's
just all about cutting down the
turnovers and you can make the same case
for Baker Mayfield right now because you
look at that preseason game Matt against
a Bucs defense that is not good it is
not a good unit no it's the worse than
the other and he did not look good now I
know a lot of people are gonna say we
need to see the real offense I get that
argument because I'm watching my team
without levy on bail on the field the
Browns want to see Odell Beckham on the
field the Baker came out and said it I
need to be better it starts with me I
think he was phenomenal in that stretch
run last year but I think maybe we need
to cool it a little bit and not expect
him to be this top 5 quarterback right
away this year maybe he is but I think
you know this other the last week's game
against the Bucks was it was a dose or
come back to reality moment yeah and I
obviously thought like I mean I know the
offensive line did not play well I
thought Baker missed on a couple throws
that we would normally see him make or
that you would expect him to make now
again I feel like I'm saying this a lot
it is the preseason but I worry so much
about Freddie kitchens is the first time
head coach because I think as quickly as
everyone jumped on the Baker train there
was at least some evidence there there
were some reasons for feeling that way
with Freddie kid
the dude came in as an interim OC and
got the head coaching job so I just want
to be fair as much as we have [ __ ] on
Kliff Kingsbury or not [ __ ] on just
being like hey let's sit let's not
forget this guy got fired at Texas Tech
I want to see it before I before I go
crazy about it the same could be said
for Freddie kitchens I need to see it
and we've we've seen too many interim
coaches who you know they just come in
and they change the right couple things
and they get some you know and us
against the world mentality and they're
able to win some ball games and keep the
job I want to see Freddie kitchens
succeed because I think he's hilarious
but I'm a little hesitant about the
Browns right now and this is a team I
picked to win the AFC North I'm a little
afraid of that prediction if it makes
you feel any better that defensive line
might be the best in football this year
I mean good it real Jameis Winston took
a beating a beating from that group the
other night Myles Garrett and Olivia
Vernon having a classic meet at the
quarterback party I think that's gonna
be a common theme this week and finally
on the preseason recap man this is a big
one Matt not only for fantasy football
implications but for we see one Domino
fall Andrew Luck retires Lamar Miller
out for the season in Houston for a
running back group that was a little
thin they add Duke Johnson to you know
give them some insurance now Duke is the
guy in Houston how do we feel about this
I love it if he can stay healthy yeah
that hamstring injuries I know he hasn't
missed a lot of time in the NFL but he
has been banged up a lot we've seen that
really affect his role in his touches
this fit is phenomenal they're gonna run
a ton out of the gun out of pistol
that's what he's best at he's a good
receiver coming out of the backfield he
has very good outside zone speed I think
they need to add another running back
still obviously ideally you would add
someone who has a little bit of power to
their game especially some short yardage
capabilities but I think this is why you
make the move to get Duke Johnson is
because Lamar Miller has unfortunately
not been able to stay healthy danta
Foreman they cut him guess what he's
already on IR with a new team so it's
just they need some consistency in that
backfield and they you know this is a
team that needs to find you know their
version of Damien Williams the Chiefs
picked him up last year after the creme
Hunt situation now he looks like he's
gonna be a really solid player for them
they almost like this needs to be your
Benny
ham type pickup you need to find someone
you know they can get the job done in a
short term until you find a long term
I'm with you I don't think you need to
spend the resources and money to go out
and panic and get Melvin Gordon and I'll
say I'd say this when the play breaks
down
deshaun Watson alongside Pat mahomes is
the best in the league possibly or at
least the most promising youngster right
now when the play breaks down when the
plate breaks down Duke Johnson turns
into a wide receiver not a running back
I think there's two I was gonna be a lot
of fun to watch Connor in his draft on a
draft time buddy let's kick it off Mike
Hubbard wants to know what player has
the most to lose in terms of draft stock
this year ie greedy Williams could it be
grant Delpit focused beyond him all year
long every single play way different
player than Quinn and Williams last year
who was under the radar that's that's
Mike's question all there
we need quotes now that you can see us
uh I don't know that there's a player
that I'm like oh this guy has the most
to lose but I will say it's really the
offensive line class as a whole because
it's easy to get excited about Andrew
Thomas or Tristan Dwarfs or even if I
Laurie Jackson's your guy or even a
walker littles your guy or Trey Adams we
have seen some really good often sublime
in the last couple years just be tore
down by the drive really a success and
even though Mike McGlinchey was still a
top-10 pick even though Jonah Williams
was an early pick they really struggled
through the process of just being torn
down by analysts by teams where you know
if the Niners hadn't taken McGlinchey he
would have fallen a decent amount if
Jonah hadn't been picked by the Bengals
I believe he would have fallen a decent
amount so I would say it's the offensive
linemen where you almost have to when
you're talking about how the NFL season
subliming you almost have to adjust for
that you almost have to look at the
curve and say okay I believe this guy
give me a top ten offensive lineman so
he's probably drafted in the late teens
because that's just how the NFL is
viewing these players now I'm with you
there I think they get ripped apart
every year whether it's arm length
whether it's positional questions
whether it's character questions it's
level of competition on and on and on
for me to counter this question I think
it might be to a tongue of AI Lowa
and I'm saying that as someone um he's
my favorite quarterback prospect and I
know Mathieu we were talking in Vegas
that you agree
with this you love - uh yes - uh playing
for Alabama throwing - Jerry Judy Henry
rugs handing it off - nah she Harris
having a good offensive line that
includes Jedrek wheels - essentially has
is expected to be perfect this year and
even if he is then he goes into the
draft process and he gets hit with the
height questions he gets hit with the
arm strength questions he gets hit with
well he had better players around him
than anyone else in this class questions
that's how it's gonna be for tua I don't
agree with it I think - is the best
quarterback in this class I think - it
should be a top five pick when all said
and done as long as he can stay healthy
but tua has basically had this bar set
for him where there's no room for a drop
off he had one week last year where he
got hurt and had a drop off and it costs
him the Heisman Trophy people [ __ ]
what do you think it's gonna do to the
draft process for him yeah I I feel like
two is gonna be a deshaun Watson type
guy where people just over think it was
Oh we'll look at because with DeSean it
was all he's not big enough and I look
at the town around him her oh he turned
the ball over too much is they don't go
to the Colts 13th overall right forget
the fact that deshaun Watson beat
Alabama basically by himself with a you
know 28 year old true freshman hunter
Renfro catching the game-winning pass so
I do agree with you that tua is the guy
that'll probably be overlooked or not
overlooked but hyper analyzed to where
people will overthink it when just watch
that dude drop the ball in the bucket
like just it's beautiful to watch him
throw the ball so I actually agree with
that one a lot Patrick Chamberlain go
for perfect attendance baby we are we
are almost nine months through the year
and I believe he has had a draft on
draft question at least submitted for
every show his question today is there
any conceivable way not involving an Eli
Manning injury that you can see the
Giants starting day no dad please he
adds a please I feel so bad okay it's
just not happening I don't know what
else to say not ownership will not let
this happen there's no way the only way
is if Jamar and Steve Tisch find out the
Eli Manning is like selling drugs on the
side like hard stuff not like some weed
like he's like movin meth
I think that's the only way that this
would have you lie Manning's meth lab oh
it's like breaking bad right listen
least expected guy ever it's I don't
know if we're gonna see Daniel jones
till the second half of the season uh
and that's if like if say Quan Barkley
carries you lime Manning to a four and
four record you're not gonna see Daniel
Jones you're not that's the crazy part
about this I look at this situation and
I would like to see Daniel Jones
I just think ownership has made it very
clear you could see the frustration
building and pat schirmer's interviews
with the media week after week because
they're asking and they're speaking for
the fans cuz the fans want to know and
Shermer is like I don't know what you
want me to say we've made our decision
and we're not we're not getting off that
decision so it's a tough one
and sorry giant stands just going to be
a little patient to see your young
quarterback in meaningful games this one
from Jack Schneider do you think Andrew
Luck retiring forces more priority on
the offensive line for NFL teams in the
future
sure but you got to find those guys just
talking about it's not like there's any
NFL team it's like you know what [ __ ] it
let's skip all the taxes actually right
like they're trying they're finally
trying like it's a bad effort trying for
NASA bills paid for offensive linemen
this offseason like teams are actually
trying to no one wants their young
quarterback to get hurt you just you
don't I mean maybe the Titans do so that
they can somehow get to a like they can
be bad enough and it's not blamed on
Mike Vrabel or John Robinson that was a
joke no if someone listings gonna be
like Matt Miller says the Titans hope
Marcus Mariota gets hurt again god I did
be careful with that sarcasm
right no I mean yes there is a ton of
focus on the offensive line but it's
just it's hard to find those guys it
really is man it's if everyone could do
it it would be a priority year after
year it's just the offensive line place
falling behind the defensive line play
it's as simple as that
so it's tough man it's some I think
teams it'll be a wake up call that maybe
you don't have your young quarterback
play through whether it's lacerations or
tears I think that's the big me remember
deshaun Watson having to take a bus to
games last year because he wasn't
medically cleared to fly right
should be a wake-up call that should be
a wake-up call yeah ja I applaud the
toughness of these guys but Josh Allen
and Lamar Jackson you don't need to take
700 hits every year great runner great
runners love it in their game protect
that body got to protect that body our
buddy Tyler Ward and I loved this
question I actually answered to him on
Twitter I'll read it here what are the
top 5 excuses I can tell to avoid seeing
people on the weekend just so I can stay
home and watch football so I saw that
you answered this one on Twitter I
wanted to actually to take this because
please one of the lessons that I've
learned from Melo over the last couple
years is he would just tell people no I
don't I don't want to see anyone this
weekend I'm gonna stay home in my hoodie
in my sweats I'm gonna watch football so
my advice to Tyler is just be honest you
do not owe anyone anything unless it's
your girl say hey it's college football
buddy weekend I'm gonna stay home I
might not leave my couch my phone will
only be on to tweet don't text me I mean
that's living the dream man
and then people know instead of like you
don't want to be like oh I'm sick cuz
you're gonna be on Twitter tweeting
about the game you don't want to kill
off a family member because I believe a
karma that [ __ ] can't happen so just say
just own it like I want to be [ __ ]
lazy and ordering tacos and watch
college football but if you have to lie
here's the five reasons I came up with
one you're you have to study for grad
school it doesn't matter if you're in
grad school or not people it'll work
they'll be like Oh Congrats like that's
so great you take that seriously - you
have a wedding somewhere that's far away
you will not be in town people will not
check on your house three you're too
hungover to leave your home very
believable because college football's on
Saturdays leave NFL's on Sundays people
do things on Friday and Saturday nights
number four watching someone's dog I
don't think you could challenge that now
you might have to put up some kind of
dog video on Instagram whether it's
yours or not five I can give some kind
of family event a dog video people do
things with their families so Matt has
kids he can't leave the house the kids
are around it'll work yeah or I mean
Tyler we gave
guy this excuse I think it was right to
years ago on a long forgotten segment we
told him that we will hire you as an
intern an unpaid volunteer intern for
the weekend you can say hey I'm doing
some work for her stick to football so I
can't I can't leave the house so in the
event that you really need an excuse we
got will take care yeah all right one
more further week this one from bar
Dale's 965 and there's Instagram DMS
with Andrew Luck's retirement due to
injuries is it safe to say Ryan Gregson
is the worst GM in NFL history from
never building a team around him I don't
think you could say that he's bad I
don't I wouldn't go as far as saying the
worst in his rad anyone who would have
taken major luck number one
I mean Stassi breath pretty bad yeah but
there's people that don't agree with
that I know I know you got to tear it
down to build that star I don't know he
drafted TYT Hilton 92nd overall that was
a good pick here we go I just think it
was mismanagement of resources right I
mean he just he made some bad picks
absolutely if I would say anything is
that he really struggled to build
through mid round picks because that's
where you see so many teams really build
their offensive line it's like okay we
have really good you know second
third-round picks on the offensive line
but I mean he did draft Ryan Kelly eight
Ryan Kelly's a stud but it was just
almost too little too late yeah well
let's go through his drafts here because
he drafted 2012 through 2016 and it's
it's not great obviously he starts out
with Andrew Luck and then he had that
two tight end draft ba after that Coby
Fleener its way now and t:y Hill and not
the worst draft okay not the worst draft
right there 2013 got really weird I mean
a complete wipeout Warner remember the
is he German right the Florida State the
Florida State kid yeah yeah that that
was a swing and miss and you won't
recognize the rest of the players that
he took after that no 2014 he took jack
new [ __ ] Donte Moncrief was a miss for
him Jonathan noose another really just a
draft that do you think they got nothing
they got nothing 2015 Phillip Dorsett
was a bad pick
yeah in the in the first round he was a
bad pick Henry Anderson in the third
round was a great pick but he doesn't
play for the Colts anymore 2016 like you
said Ryan Kelly and TJ green I mean blue
Raven Clarke it's not great he's not the
worst GM ever but he's on the list yeah
I mean I I honestly think one of the
things that really hurt rank Grigson was
that his college scouting staff there's
a reason those dudes aren't like popping
up anywhere else yeah and we've talked
about that with Ballard he has had dogs
he had Rex Hogan like you have to build
a good staff under you yes so I think
that's a big part Minh not the worst in
history I've I've seen some [ __ ] guys
that is not but Hobie that's bad people
will view him as the guy that ruined
Andrew Luck oh yeah without a doubt
and I mean bad about Ted Thompson and
Aaron Rodgers yeah I don't know it's an
interesting debate I mean your Jets have
had worse GM oh I went out a day Trent
Baalke era without a doubt we've had
worse jams but yet Mike Tannenbaum
tannenbaum got a soon AFC Championship
good John Innes is the worst yet people
always forget the guy after I Wolf Man
it's a great discussion I actually think
that's a good I Tunes review for the
week who do you think the worst GM is of
all time and if you don't have a stand
that who's the worst GM of your favorite
NFL franchise I like that a lot all
right that is our show Connor is out so
to be me and Melo holding it down Friday
it's gonna be a lot of this brick wall
behind me and a lot of Melo we're gonna
have fun previewing week one of the
college football season so if you're if
you're looking forward to like an
in-depth preview of week one we're gonna
give it to you
Friday morning six football on Apple
podcasts now YouTube stitcher Spotify
we're taking all OVR gridiron we'll have
tons of social clip outs on be our
gridiron and of course follow the stick
to football accounts I mean we just had
some pretty kick-ass interviews in Las
Vegas what else key asked for